are you sick of all the fees and the
hassle of having a checking account at a
big bank check out our sponsor current
using the link below I'll tell you more
about them at the end of the video so
Twitter for the first time has flagged
Trump tweets as possibly misleading
essentially a flag they've established a
signal fake news and Donald Trump has
absolutely lost his mind and is talking
even about shutting down social media
platforms that do this now I told you
yesterday that Twitter they kind of have
special rules for politicians and
prominent figures where normally for
example you would not be allowed to
accuse random people of murder on
Twitter and SiC your followers on them
but Donald Trump did that to Joe
Scarborough and Twitter allows it
because they say when Trump does it it
in and of itself is newsworthy and thus
it should be allowed to stay because it
is the a catalyst for much reporting
it's newsworthy in in and of itself
because of the person who is doing it
so yesterday Donald Trump sent out two
tweets with absolute lies about
vote-by-mail and Twitter flagged them
both and provided fact-checking and
Donald Trump lost his you-know-what and
this is a technique that Twitter put in
place similar to one that Facebook has
when fake news articles are posted and
this is infuriating to Trump let's check
out the claims and then the truth and
this is so important not just because
good for Twitter for fact-checking the
president but it's important because
vote-by-mail is again becoming sort of
like the new battle line in the upcoming
20/20 election Donald Trump said there
is no way zero that mail-in ballots will
be anything less than substantially
fraudulent mail boxes will be robbed
ballots will be forged and even
illegally printed out and fraudulently
signed the government of California the
governor of California is sending
ballots to millions of people anyone
living in the state no matter who they
are or how they got there will get one
that will be followed up with
professionals telling all of these
people many of whom have never even
thought of voting before how and for
whom to vote this will be a rigged
election no way now as you can see if
you're looking at this
there's a flag there with an exclamation
point that says get the facts about
mail-in ballots sort of an instant fact
check which tells you if you click it
that Donald Trump is falsely claiming
that mail-in ballots would lead to a
rigged election that's not true there's
no evidence that mail-in ballots are
linked to voter fraud Trump falsely
claims California is going to send
mail-in ballots to anyone no matter how
they got there implying undocumented
immigrants would get ballots in fact not
only is that not true
only registered voters would receive
ballots if you live in California but
are not registered to vote you won't get
a ballot at all five states have already
voted entirely by mail all states offer
some kind of absentee voting according
to NBC News also part of the fact check
now the right-wingers who love to cry
about anti conservative discrimination
on Twitter and Facebook
they are slamming Twitter for this but
this is exactly what Twitter needs to be
doing CNN and MSNBC and Fox News should
be doing it during Trump and Caylee
maghen Annie's press briefings I've
talked about responsible platforming
instant fact-checking
this is how Donald Trump's tweets should
also be handled now the amazing thing is
when Twitter did this Trump tweeted an
apology for spreading fake news Trump
deleted his tweets and he thanked
Twitter for correcting him no obviously
that's not true
Trump absolutely lost it when Twitter
did this attacking them and CNN and the
Washington Post for some reason tweeting
quote Twitter is now interfering in the
twenty20 presidential election they're
saying my statement on mail-in ballots
which will lead to massive corruption
and fraud is incorrect
based on fact-checking by fake news CNN
and the Amazon Washington Post adding
that quote Twitter is completely
stifling free speech and I as president
will not allow it to happen then Trump
actually tweeting about shutting
platforms down tweeting quote
Republicans feel that social media
platforms totally silenced conservatives
voices we will strongly regulate or
close them
before we can ever allow this to happen
we saw what they attempted to do and
failed in 2016 we can't let a more
sophisticated version of that happen
again
just like we can't let large-scale
mail-in ballots take root in our country
it would be a free-for-all on cheating
forgery and the theft of ballots who
ever cheated the most would win
likewise social media clean up your act
now extremely dangerous dystopian
totalitarian language from the president
we cannot relent on this I implore
Twitter not to relent
I implore other platforms and media
outlets on TV to do the exact same thing
instant fact-checking of Donald Trump
what would be amazing would be if
Twitter fact-checked Trump's attack on
Twitter right like is interference in
the elections inclusive of just
fact-checking the president no that's a
lie our Trump's claims about massive
corruption and fraud incorrect yes those
are not true is fact-checking by CNN
incorrect no Trump is wrong now it
should be mentioned this is the
president saying Twitter doing fact
checks has something to do with the
Constitution's first amendment Trump is
accusing Twitter of violating his First
Amendment rights can you imagine can you
imagine a president this incompetent
when it comes to the basics of what the
First Amendment is twitter has the same
First Amendment right to decide which
falsehoods and lies they will allow to
spread on their private platform just
like other private businesses have the
ability and right to do this was a big
topic when I was on with Joe Rogan on
Friday
what should the limits be here whose
rights extend how far when it comes to
what Twitter can be compelled to do
versus what Twitter is allowed to do as
an organization that has terms and
conditions Trump is going to put huge
pressure on Twitter and other platforms
it is very clear this is part of the
culture war
this is part
the battle lines now I want this to
escalate Twitter actually could get
Trump to completely lose his mind if
they keep up the fact checking with his
of his tweets with accurate information
good for Twitter I'm not endorsing or
criticizing anything else about Twitter
other than this is the right thing to do
they should keep doing it look at how
instantly triggered Donald Trump was
will follow what will certainly be a
wild next 24 to 48 hours as the fallout
from this continues keep an eye out one
other warning and then I want to move on
keep an eye out for how people around
Trump are going to create specious
special pleadings to argue that Twitter
should be banned from doing this
essentially we'll follow up on that when
it happens let's give it time to develop
we often talk about the many different
ways that big banks take advantage of
their customers and one of our sponsors
today is current which is an online bank
for those of us who were sick of dealing
with all of the fees and the nonsense
from the big banks I use current myself
if you're watching this on YouTube
here's my actual current debit card that
I'm holding up no minimum balance they
have 24/7 support no overdraft fees up
to $100 and it won't get declined no ATM
fees you can use over 55,000 ATMs
nationwide and unlike other banks you
receive your direct deposits instantly
which means you'll get paid by your
employer up to two days sooner you can
deposit checks instantly using your
camera phone and unlike other banks
current instantly refunds the hold on
your card from pumping gas you can pause
your debit card instantly also really
useful in many situations there are just
so many different advantages to ditching
the big banks and instead use a bank
that puts their members first it takes
two minutes to sign up they'll
immediately ship you your debit card for
free go ahead and get started by
clicking the link down below the video